all right one two three
[Laughter]
oh my god
[Music]
that's so strange i've never had either
of these
you've never had a twinkie
never had a twinkie oh wow this is
amazing i get to be present for your
first tweaking moment
this is like
so american i don't know i think it's
more american wait which one's a twinkie
this is a twinkie okay so that appears
to be a sort of pie
a cherry pie which one let's try twinkie
first
okay
okay i'm so excited all right
okay okay
cool thing about these is they literally
last forever i think like
if you get one of these when you're a
kid you can like keep in your safe
deposit box
and you're like 50 you can just take it
out have you done that
no i i my parents found some in my room
when i moved out that were probably 10
years old
but they ate them
enough is your outfit
[Music]
well i gotta say
this one's nostalgic so i like it but
that's just outstanding this one's
really good
whoa
okay toxic waste
what is this okay i haven't had this in
a while but like they're oh my god
i'm so excited all right one two three
[Laughter]
oh my god
if i'm making your face like you this is
hilarious
whoa
i wanted to have you have to finish it
that's too much
and the british ones are there licorice
all sorts
i'm not the best with licorice
what are you doing i'll just keep this
in my mouth and eat this too no you can
ditch it
okay
[Applause]
okay see i'm not the biggest licorice
lover okay my mom would love this
[Music]
it's pretty good right yeah
i think these are delightful
i'm sorry but the toxic waste
[Music]
i know what these are going to taste
like yeah okay
sort of a pretzel sort of nut
this looks like a tree branch
it does is that just me okay it looks
like a twig
oh whoa
whoa
oh i didn't expect it to taste like that
twig
twiglets i'll take twiglets brown are
you going for twiglets today yeah
it's two for twiglets
interesting i love jerky me too let me
go for that one but um
oh no
this is so good
i'm sorry this is this has to be
one of my favorites so far
delicious
kind of lemony
pickled onion that's why
i love pickles so
probably
uk is killing it we're gonna pick this
one i guess we didn't even have to try
that one huh
i have that like all the time
oh my gosh that was so good i love new
trying new things and that's fantastic
so the winner is
the uk wow
yeah guys thank you you have some
beautiful snacks i want to come over
here
i want to try more
you've never tried salt licorice
beforehand sir i'm very excited to see
this
holy sh
sorry welcome to oh my god
you people are crazy this is how we
treat ourselves that actually burned my
tongue
i can't believe you give that to
children